Through me doing stand up.
Gene Simmons came to see me do stand up
at new years and a in La and then his
son,
uh,
like listened to one
of my cds and liked it.
So you drag the whole family out.
Oh Wow.
I've never been starstruck before.
A show where I was like,
I felt weird about to go on stage.
I'm going to go,
I'm about to go on stage.
I couldn't,
it wasn't a normal show,
it just couldn't be a normal show.
It was just too weird to
me when I was a little kid.
Like I was little,
like seven or eight years old
or whatever the fuck it was.
I guess I was probably like 11 when,
when,
when kiss was big.
Um,
I remember like thinking they were the
greatest thing in the history of the
world,
you know,
like this is the greatest
band of all time.
Like I was a huge,
huge kiss fan.
So to like to be standing there as a
grown man and he's a grown man and,
and we're at my show.
I'm like,
that's just too fucking weird.
It's just too much for me.
I had to address it.
How to address,
I has shifted my whole act around
address it cause I have
something that whole
music thing.
No,
I don't see Tim is chuck.
Luckily I didn't write,
uh,
there are some people there
like some young girls who,
who uh,
who would be more
starstruck by Gene Simmons,
his son.
She saw the two of them walking down
the street or some young in general.
Well he's a reality star.
Yeah.
He's a handsome devil.
Very tall.
The whole family is very tall.
When they were hugging me,
I felt like their child,
uh,
all of them is following
them around for Valerie show.
No,
it was legit.
It was just regular shell.
Did you know there's an abandoned zoo
and a la and the Griffith Park and London
zoo?
Yeah,
it closed in the 1960s.
It,
when was the first zoo in Los Angeles?
I,
they closed it down because
it was so fucking small.
And so they raised money for
the current zoo and so they,
it was like a mile down the street.
And so now I found out the other day
that you can actually go to this zoo.
It's still there and
they've gone through it.
Yeah,
they filmed the movie anchorman.
There's a scene in it from that movie.
So anyways,
you go through like this weird trail
and he'd go through this parking lot and
then you end up in this
zoo and it looks like,
you know,
like this is where the Tigers,
where this is where the elephants were.
And then there's like all these cages
where they used to be like gorillas and
stuff like that.
And what's so cool?
It's fucking creepy.
Like,
like it's been grown over,
like there's plants and
stuff like that and it,
half of the shits like still standing
how they're half is like crumbling.
Uh,
but people hang out there and like we'll
put bring blankets and there was like,
like people playing the
doors and one of the cells.
So you're just walking down
the here with Jim Morrison,
just kind of echoing through lessons.
A little fantastical.
I mean,
I live really close to
there and it's not like,
it's not that like,
it's just,
it's a field like right when you
drive in it off Riverside there,
right.
It's just a pass,
like the merry go round thing and there's
a big field and then some old cages.
You're freaking me out man.
And then,
and then we know about these doors.
Did you make of the old
house and talk to us?
He told us to go when it turns out he's
been dead for five
c we climbed,
we're in the animals walk up
and down or through the back,
you know?
And there was like people,
graffiti artists like really awesome.
Like oh you saw this?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
And behind that,
behind the there was like,
you know,
like a big drawing of like a gorilla face
screaming behind this badge of someone
that just club you over the head.
And the next thing you know,
taking your ass.
That was in the dream when I thought it
was the creepiest though it was mostly
women and girls like
just hanging out there.
I never,
stuff like that.
So it's a hangout people hang out at,
it's like a park on that,
but it was at night during the day.
So it's a former zoo that you could
walk through it and anybody can walk.
Yeah.
And it closed.
And then in the 60s and
then you can really explore,
there's a lot of trails you can find
like old things that like you can't,
it would be really cool to
see the blueprint and like,
oh all right,
this is where this used to be.
This word is cause there's a,
it's like a ghost town.
It's creepy as fuck.
I was working on most of it.
But it sounds,
what you're saying is yeah,
I was working for a private
investigator once and um,
I used to have to do a lot of drive and
forum and we were out in the middle of
fucking nowhere,
like way,
way far away.
And it was driving back home and I was
bored and I don't remember the town,
but it was a town in the
middle of fucking nowhere.
And I saw a sign that said the zoo
for whatever the fuck this town was.
I mean,
I'm in the middle of nowhere.
So I pull in and I go,
okay,
let's see what this
fucking zoos all about.
So I go there,
there's a tiger that is
in like a swimming pool.
I mean,
this fucking has nowhere to move and it
keeps pacing back and forth and back and
forth.
And that's as far as I got.
I got to that thing and I was just so
freaked out by the obvious madness that I
was seeing that they had taken
some animal and put it in wood.
It's really like a swimming pool and
this fucking thing is just going back and
forth and back and forth,
and there's no room for him.
A swimming pool on its side.
When I say a swimming pool,
it's like the size of a
swimming pool and it's cement.
I mean,
it's just this weird fucking thing
that this poor creature is stuck in.
He's pacing back and
forth and I'm watching it.
I'm like,
this is madness.
Like there's some like really tiny ass
zoos and some places for little fucking
animals are just,
you know,
even if you go to a nicest,
who though does that
not ever freak you out?
I can't,
I don't like that feeling
of looking at these.
I mean it's cool that
we could see them all.
I mean I was spoiled educational.
I grew up one by one of the best zoos
and probably some people consider it the
whole country or whatever.
Yeah,
the Columbus Zoo where Jack hand
is frowning and all that stuff.
So ours do,
it was a little bit cooler they had,
cause it's Ohio,
they had like farm land,
you know,
where it was just like this elephant
was in like its own like woods.
Like it was like it didn't look like a k.
There was just,
you know,
big huge exhibits.
Do you think it bothers them though?
Okay.
It's take it,
if it gets big enough then it's okay.
Is that the justification?
I think.
I think like,
do you know you,
you know that you're on,
you know where you're at right now.
You know,
if you grew up on an island like
Hawaii or something like that,
I mean that's a way bigger.
But you know,
elephants,
they just want a big thing of grass.
I don't think they care like to go hiking.
Are you saying that
elephants are in Hawaii?
I'm so
[inaudible] equation,
I'm talking about like if animals
have enough space so they have like,
you know,
football fields.
I agree.
The San Diego.
Yeah,
San Diego Wild Animal Park is pretty dope.
And like the one animals that
definitely seem happy or the giraffes,
they're just kind of like chilling
and eating and wandering around.
And there's like no
one there to jack them,
you know,
which is,
if you're like [inaudible] or an antelope
or a fucking giraffe or anything,
you're always thinking something's
going to Jack you eventually.
You know,
you ever see the videos of,
um,
of them taking down giraffes of lions
taken down giraffes cause a bunch of them
on that line is,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
One of them,
there's a lion and a n two lionesses
and they take down this giraffe in the
middle of a street.
And these people are filming
this from their fucking car.
They're inside their car and they're
filming it through the windshield.
And this fucking lion takes down
this giraffe right in front of them.
It's why I'll dude,
so fucking primal.
Oh,
you're right there and this thing,
it's just,
Ooh,
a shirt is so bad ass.
Yeah.
I got a bird crusher to shit on.
I don't think so.
That is beautiful.
It says I am the machine.
If you don't know Bert Kreischer as a
fucking hilarious story that he told them
this podcast,
which is amazing story of him and Russia.
And it's so funny.
So somebody animated that one,
right?
Yeah.
If I,
if I remember correctly,
it's like in the hundreds
of thousands now.
Yeah.
Fucking hilarious.
I'll find it later and
I'll tweet it tonight.
But,
uh,
you know,
Bert Kreischer,
he's been on the podcast a bunch of
times and he's one of the funniest guys.
Crazy story.
I heard it.
He did it at the Improv,
but he's so funny.
He's such a fun guy to be around,
man.
I didn't realize his like,
history.
I mean,
I just,
you know,
he's just the guy that I
met around doing comedy,
but I didn't know that he was like,
like the king of college
partiers and while stem
wild,
it was like such a nice guy.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
It's like he's a,
he's a partner.
Yeah.
But he like,
he doesn't have a fucking mean bone.
Yeah,
no,
no.
And he hangs out with his fans like,
like that one guy that monkey Todd.
Awesome.
Nancy grace video,
by the way.
Did you see that Nancy Grace Video?
It was beautiful.
Stewed called up Nancy
Grace and ask Nancy grace,
you know,
what is it who you want to marry?
Fuck or kill?
Yeah.
And she,
he asked her,
well,
would you rather like one marry,
kill or fuck a red band,
Sam Aaa or Jason Tebow?
And he says on Tmz live really racist.
Just sitting there like,
like you could kind of look
like she was going to smile,
but then it'd become angry.
And then monkey Todd goes
and would you dry hump?
Uh,
Sam Aaa and then uh,
Harvey,
the TMZ hosts.
This is what their first serious interview
I heard like they were like really like,
like wow,
this is the first time we have
a serious interview Harvey.
It's like,
is this serious?
Really like it,
it's uncomfortable to watch that video,
don't you think?
No nonsense.
She is not juggle babies,
animals full.
Laura,
did you know she was with
tapes or an office that big?
Big.
Yeah.
Well you know,
getting fretting about
dead babies and Florida,
it allows you a lot of freedom
to eat Cheetos and stuff.
Your face with brandings.
You're all dead babies.
It doesn't seem positive.
Ring Ding.
If thought Doni this rating thing cause
this baby and Florida going to be alive
now.
I don't think so.
She just eats it.
She's,
it's hard to stay slim.
There's so many dead babies.
It's hard to say this last
baby she has like twin babies,
which doesn't seem right.
Like she doesn't seem
like child bearing now.
It seems like that should
be physically impossible.
Her eggs should it be just fucking
fighting to the death in there?
I questioned it.
I looked at her eggs should
look like a gladiator seen
fighting each other.
Keep magic.
She just had the pants.
Pussy ever just choose way,
just like a fist.
Imagine just like jerking you off of
her vagina muscles do have you seen that
Russian bitch online that can carry
like 30 pounds of their pussy?
I don't know how it works and
she doesn't really show the Gash,
but she's got like videos on how to like
control your pussy muscle so that you
can like pick up weight.
You know,
like she would just fucking crush
your dick just getting in there.
Maybe it would be too tight.
It would be uncomfortable.
Like a wrestling match with your Dick.
You know,
he'll like dogs.
I like dogs when they fuck,
they got a real problem because dogs
have a bone and that bone gets locked in
there like a fish hook and
sometimes they get stuck.
That's fucking pain.
Cats do.
And her jagged dicks.
Catholic.
It's jagged.
What do you do in jerking off cat son?
Well,
you see a cat.
That's why if you hear it,
that's why.
If you ever catch you seeking,
they're screaming.
Oh Wow.
So it's,
it's painful.
It's painful for their female cat.
That's nuts.
You should Google Google
cap penis right now.
You'd be shocked.
It looks like,
uh,
I've been tricked before,
but not that easily,
Brian.
Not that easily.
That penis,
penis.
Seriously.
Look at it.
I guess I need to know that everybody
knows who his dog Dick looks like,
but very few people know.
No,
you've never seen it.
it didn't go take a look.
Okay.
I see little Barbie looking things.
Cat,
penis,
spines.
They're called,
my goodness.
He's telling the truth.
This is horrific.
Nature is so ruthless.
You know what it is.
That's to ensure that the,
the,
the male stays in there
and shoots his load.
This is horrendous.
Nature is so God damn vicious.
What a vicious fucking
animal in nature is,
are all cats would just
loosen up a little bit.
They wouldn't take their Barbie Penis.
You know,
that's a wild world.
We're living in a world of the cats.
You know,
big cats.
Jaguars are little baby
cats out there killing mice.
It's just the same thing.
It's all wild world of,
of fucking moving and killing
things smaller than you.
You know,
you can't,
we can't even understand what it must
be like to try and get some cat pussy.
You know?
You should imagine.
Could you imagine this bitch is in agony.
She wants to fuck so bad.
She's in agony,
but she knows that you're
going to rip her insides up,
but that needle he dick,
she wants you to just keep
talk being with no needles,
the needles
and they just circle each other.
That could be a good like let's
write that script cat man like he,
but he just has that Barbie peanut.
That's why
cats,
you know what they liked?
They liked those fluffy
cats that just give up,
you know like what are those called?
What was yours called?
Persians.
Just give up.
They just a little slutty cats.
They just relax and just take it.
That's why I like a big Tom cat with
like a Persian cat around the house so he
could just fuck it.
Random,
you know,
she's not going to fight back much.
You know,
she's going to barely fight back.
She can't fuck with him
being black street cat.
It's like the Kardashians.
They're Persian,
aren't they?
No.
They're Armenian.
Did you just make a joke about
Armenian somewhere on Twitter recently,
so no,
I don't think so.
Have you ever worn a long exactly on par.
Oh,
Jen Kirkman tweeted something.
Yeah.
She tweeted something about,
what?
Is it,
an Armenian holiday today or something?
I Dunno,
is it?
She said something shit.
I called it.
She said she wasn't going to make any
sarcastic tweets about the Kardashians in
honor of some Armenian day,
and I called her and ask us.
That was the whole,
I didn't say anything negative
about Armenians.
I know you would never do that.
Right?
I would never say anything negative
about a group of people that proud
Armenians.
They love being Armenian.
You know,
there's a lot of Armenians who were like,
fuck,
I wish it wasn't you.
No.
They love being Armenians.
You know,
they're proud people.
Carl Breezy and duty
used to fight the UFC.
Fucking what a personality that guy has.
He's hilarious.
I got this thing that he,
we were having lunch.
I got to ask him if I
could put this video out.
It's a video of him
joking around about he,
his nickname was the heat and joking
around about giving girls the heat and
telling them,
what are you doing?
You're taking the heat.
They take the heat.
He's like yelling about it and he's like,
he's so Armenian.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's so fucking hilarious.
You know those,
those really aggressive,
funny Armenian type guys.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know a ton of them.
I've only lived out here for
like extreme Italians years.
They're like extreme.
Like I actually had Armenians hook me
up at the tire center the other day,
which was the most weirdest thing.
There were six Armenians.
They all came out circle
around the car and was like,
hey,
how's it going?
Oh you got two nails in your tires
will change them and patch them.
And he goes,
you know what?
It's on us.
And I'm like,
what?
Really?
That's awesome.
Fuck is he though?
Yo,
you always hear bad things about people,
Russian people
and Armenian people and you know,
people from what we
consider like hard places.
You know,
I've,
I've made a lot of great,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean are people like a lot of passion?
You know,
there's a,
it's a,
it says something about
real ethnic groups,
you know,
a real group like the Armenian is,
like they stick to their culture.
And when I was growing up,
our startup culture is kind of bullshit.
Like who gives a fuck?
You know,
like,
you know,
does it really matter if you behave
exactly the way everybody else behaves?
But when you see like a really tight
knit ethnic community and you appreciate,
not that they're racist or
biased against anybody else,
but that they have like this
real distinct flavor to them,
you know,
the way they behave,
the,
the things they like,
you know,
they have this real distinct,
let's see,
real uniqueness to it
that makes it interesting.
It's one of the interesting
things about life.
You know,
the,
one of the things I was thinking about
when I was in New Orleans this weekend,
I was like,
this is a completely different
way to live your life.
Like here there's these
people that are living in,
this is a totally different flavor,
a very unique flavor of its own.
You know,
it alls was like a race.
like Norland people are almost
like it's from another country.
But I think that,
you know,
when,
when people get assimilated it's the,
you mean the perfect thing is to have
everybody be cool with everybody.
And there's,
you know,
and no,
no people who are prejudice against any
particular group because we're all some
sort of weird shade of gray.
Now we've all interbred to the point
where there's no distinctiveness between
you.
No,
no,
no way of distinguishing
us between anybody else.
We're all just one sort of
individual type of thing.
But along the way,
man,
we're going to lose a lot of fun.
You know,
there's a lot of fun and people being
weird because a lot of fun and you know,
Armenian dudes who are like
suit wearing gold chains.
And try to get some pussy.
Those guys are awesome man.
Yeah,
those guys are fucking,
the Kardashians are Armenians.
I believe that they know.
But our is that like if you
make fun of the Kardashians,
like as an Armenian Guy gonna Punch
me and I don't think they claim,
um,
claim them cause it seems like
she's trying to get a white girl.
It's different,
you know,
think are Armenian women.
I don't want to speak for Armenian women.
They'll say,
well less.
They have to like forget about
whatever the fuck you know.
She's,
you know,
is she worthwhile and she worth anything.
What's the point?
We're talking about her.
So she's entertaining just as like Max
and Ruby is a cartoon that my kids love.
It's this little rabbit show.
It's a fucking show.
It's entertaining.
Maybe not to you.
I've never heard of kids to someone.
This Kardashians show is fucking awesome.
All right.
Oh that's that person.
They deserve it.
It's ridiculous.
As ridiculous as it is.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I dunno if the Armenians
claimer but they should,
you see that she's a bad ass bitch when
it comes to like being like good at
that.
You know,
you've got to recognize Paris Hilton,
who she took the Paris Hilton thing.
So some completely new level to the point
where every time I'm at the airport,
I'm my fucking sneakers into a bin.
I'm looking at her face just like ads
where it's her and a couple of other
famous people and I,
every time I'm like,
wow,
this girl started off in
a fucking porno movie.
Now I'm putting my change on her face.
It's so strange,
you know?
But you got to,
I love it.
I love the madness of it.
I love how ridiculous it is.
I've gotten to the point
where I love Rick Perry.
I see him talk and I know,
I know he's of stutter and fuck.
I know he's just like Bush.
I know he's going to
do the exact same shit.
Maybe even weirder.
You know,
maybe if he reminds me of dude.
Yeah,
Josh Brolin playing w in the movie.
That's what it reminds me.
And I look at it,
but I like it.
I like that he's there.
I'm enjoying that he's there.
I mean gang,
but then you can,
then it's just like,
so I don't know what was
given up on everything,
you know?
I mean that's kind of in the
same boat where it's like,
all right.
I mean I can either be walking around
like furious out of my mind all the time
or just like don't really pay attention
to it and enjoy the absurdity of it all.
It's like watching Mitt
Romney and Rick Perry,
like I just saw on the news.
I don't know what they were like
debating each other and it's like,
who's crazier?
Who believes in crazier Shit Dude?
Like that's like from an eighties and
look like they're like politicians.
They are like the archetype like bad
politician guy from like an eighties movie
or something.
It's just like this like robot dude.
They're both exactly the same.
I think when you take your choice,
we're getting a real clear message,
a real clear message with politics
over the last decade or so.
It's that what you are
seeing on television,
the people that are talking,
that's the guy who got that spot.
That's all that is,
and that guy is,
he's,
he's instructed,
he's pushed into a certain direction
for all the people who got him to that
position.
It's so clear.
It's so obvious there's,
there can be no denying it
when you look at it now,
to take it seriously,
as in,
you know,
to take it,
to think that there's really some sort
of a big vote going on and we're going to
change the way the whole thing works.
Hey,
I hear they're going to throw out,
the Federal Reserve is going to go back
to the only live in by the constitution.
We're going to cut the number
of laws back dramatically.
We've got to let people
have state's rights again.
Yeah,
we're,
can I get rid of all,
how long would that last?
No,
they would kill that guy.
They would kill that guy.
The heartbeat.
Oh yeah.
Of course.
We all,
we all agreed that the guy's saying like,
uh,
no,
I don't think I can sign that
bill called the clean air act.
That actually lets you pollute
more when people tell you,
well that's ridiculous.
You're being cynical.
This is a terrible message to send out.
You haven't really researched
this enough to be APP.
Absolutely accurate.
You get,
you're saying this damaging thing that
voting doesn't change anything and you're
sending a terrible message to people,
but at what point in time are
you allowed to be objective?
At what point in time do you look at a
guy like Obama who acts like a Republican
and does all this creepy shit that if
GE Gw was doing it and liberals would be
fucking calling into newspapers
every day and protesting every day,
he's doing shit.
Does just like the stuff that Bush
did and yet somehow or another.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I really,
somehow or another liberals aren't
even saying anything about it.
It's the whole,
it's so bizarre.
Lee.
Creepy and so bizarrely weird.
Just like windows versus PC.
It's like the same sort
of retard battle going on.
It's the same sort of weird control
over some fucking boat that doesn't even
have a steering wheel.
It's like one day you break
into the fucking main cabin.
All right?
We finally got to the head of the boat.
There's no stairs,
there's nothing.
There's no instruments.
It's smooth as glass.
You can affect this fucking thing at all.
You could spend your whole life chipping
away at this insanely corrupt system.
Good luck.
Look at when we,
when you see anybody like challenges,
any,
any of the mainstream ideas
that we've come to accept.
Like look at a guy like Ron Paul.
They'd duct that fucking
guy every chance they get.
I've seen polls where they ignore the
number one guy and focus on the two and
three,
the real battle between
Rick Perry and Mitt Romney.
And they were,
they were literally ignoring
that Ron Paul was winning things.
Just ignoring them.
Just not even talking to them.
Yeah.
Because he's just telling him they're,
they're doing everything wrong.
We're doing everything wrong.
The people are going yes.
And the TV.
Well,
it's like when Howard got,
when Howard Dean said,
yeah,
just fucking but has never fucking,
he fucked up.
I fucked up.
You fucked up.
I think they set him up to manipulate,
like they took that footage
and twisted it into something.
Well,
I remember it was morning
mattress material.
There was a,
there was a show that I was thinking
of when I think of morning shows,
Charles Laquidara the mattress
in the morning and Boston.
Oh,
okay.
They would play something
along these lines.
So you know that every fucking single
wacky morning zoo radio station that crazy
yelled at her,
yelled out and it became a joke.
It became a national joke
in the matter of a day.
You remember it,
right?
Howard Dean did a campaign
speech and he's like,
Hey,
we're gonna Fairmont in New Hampshire.
And all they did was take that.
Yeah.
They're like,
no fucking way,
dude.
You can't ever,
yeah.
Resident.
They took it from like his body,
Mike,
when he was yelling to like,
you know,
a couple thousand people.
But could you imagine if Obama ever,
yeah,
well,
ever since.
How are we managing that?
You're not allowed to
show any emotion anymore.
I mean that's,
they have playbooks
now where they're like,
no,
don't show any emotion.
Just put the,
this is still in when you make your fist,
isn't it?
Isn't it amazing?
And don't ever answer a fucking
question no matter what you do.
Never fucking give a direct,
definitive.
Once people decide that
Howard Dean has done,
Howard Dean has done and he just pushed
to the side like he was the front
runner.
He was the number one surgeon
from Vermont.
Like,
you know,
you man,
brilliant man.
Wait,
speaker.
Got a little
emotion.
Good morals.
Yeah.
Fuck Outta here.
You know,
I kind of like him even more now because
he's so uncensored when he talks about
things and for months a
very interesting place too.
He's from Vermont.
It's amazing.
It's like,
it's really northern in rural,
but it's really smart.
Have you ever done a Gig there?
Yeah,
I've done that.
A gig in Burlington when
I was living in Boston,
I did a weekend there once
was fucking great man.
I was like,
wow,
what a crazy.
And they were like,
winter's are tough though.
What he said,
I have a friend who lives
in Brattleboro and uh,
yeah,
winter's are fucking,
I wouldn't want to be there.
No winner.
There's a certain quality of your
life that you sacrifice when you,
you know,
you,
you live in someplace.
It's brutally cold.
Well it's the way it's
so rural that you have,
everybody's got like a 45 foot kind of
dirt driveway thing and then when it
snows and freezes,
it's like you can't drive my truck
down there fucking to know a tree.
Well up in big bear.
A lot of people drive around
with fucking chains on.
Yeah,
I think,
well yeah,
you can do hires.
I think you were required
areas and she used to be,
you know,
I know they make like
studded snow tires and shit,
so you can deal with that.
Like a lot of people in Colorado,
they had that,
but no changes are required.
Yeah.
That a place like Vermont,
it's fucking cold for a
good five or six months.
It's really cold.
Fuck.
Is it beautiful up there though?
Man,
it's one of the few places that's
like hasn't been fucked with,
you know,
because there's just,
it's,
it's a fairly small population and it's a,
it's got an incredible amount of wildlife
and incredible amount of like woods
and just beautiful nature shit to look at.
You know,
when you drive and drive up to Burlington,
you're like,
look how beautiful it is.
Just clear air and not that many people.
And it's almost all outdoor advertising
and Vermont to no billboards,
no outdoor,
you can't advertise outdoors.
Wow.
Yeah,
the real hippie.
That's where Ben and Jerry comes from.
Ben and Jerry's ice cream,
they came from their real
super happy up there.
Are they up there so you can actually
go to the factory and to the dude's live
up there too or did they fucking fake it
and they're in Miami getting made Dick
suck prime.
I don't know any magic there.
You imagine that they were just became
super rich and they just became ballers,
but then they'd have to like put
it on the fucking Birkenstocks.
So their ad campaigns,
they just want to be out there doing blow.
And that's a funny idea.
That'd be a funny like sketch mad big
hippies like fake Ben and Jerry get those
guys and when they get big or like p
diddy and fucking just totally shift here.
Ben and Jerry's becomes like Mcdonald's
where a different guy plays it in every
store.
Hey Jerry.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You have a fucking Ben and Jerry's show
that goes on before the actual ice cream
gets served.
Yeah.
I'm Ben and he's Jerry.
How are you?
Sure.
I thought I was jewelry.
Yeah.
How the fuck did that
Mcdonald's thing happened?
Remember when there's a real clowns,
Justin up as Mcdonald's and you can
go to Mcdonald's like certain days and
Ronald McDonald would be
there and you're like,
shit,
this has got a Ronald
Mcdonald's going to be at this.
When people get excited about it,
how ruthless has Mcdonald.
They still do that.
I had a roommate who was a clown.
He really do.
Ronald McDonald Shit appearance.
Amazing.
Now,
what a tricky way to rope kids in eight
and your fucking food man to think that
about.
You know,
when you think about the most delicious
serial as all the worst shit for you,
that's all the ones with the
big attractive cartoon faces on.
It literally is designed
to get little kids and go,
Ooh,
look like to them serial
called cookie crisp.
Yeah.
That's not going to be a feeling of a kid.
Well,
you could have a cereal box that was all
white that said captain crunch peanut
butter,
and you would look at it and go,
fuck yeah,
you could be completely
white with like black letter.
But to a kid that's going to be
completely unattractive because they can't
fucking read.
They're getting them before they
can even can read that and go,
I want this.
Like my three year old can't read,
but she looks at captain
crunch and it looks fun.
You look at fruity pebbles and fun.
They still make Bogue,
blueberries,
blueberry.
In Ohio,
there was no such thing as booberry.
They had only the strawberry
and the chocolate,
but then I would go on vacation in.
And what was the Franken
Franken Berry Berry.
Did you feel left out?
I would go to Florida on vacation again,
five boxes of it it or
you haul a mom very like,
mom,
please,
I,
this is my favorite series,
so she'll spend like $30 and
buy as much booberry $30 oil,
a little scrappy.
It was rude.
There's no reason for that.
Blueberries is the best one and you
don't sell it in certain markets?
I think I've ever had
booberry oh that's great.
That's great.
Or the strawberry on going to cvs,
they saw my folks wouldn't
buy us the sugary stuff.
I mean I've had it had
it as an adult.
Good,
good for them.
My parents bought it very sparingly.
They let us have it every now and then
you'd like pick a favorite to just eat
the stupid shit they would,
they would indulge us.
Lou would also let us eat TV dinners.
We wanted a TV dinner,
shots,
stories and they're disgusting.
But were for whatever reason,
I saw the very steak.
I want to eat a TV dinner,
wanting eat the dumbest shit.
So they would let me every now and then.
But for the most part,
they wanted me to eat healthy,
so I didn't get to eat too many of those,
but,
but when I could,
when I got a chance,
man,
oh fuck.
Yeah.
Well like what we were
talking about earlier,
once you tell people they can't do shit,
then it's on.
It's like,
really?
I want some of that.
Yeah.
You mentioned if you grew up a Vegan
you would just like hunger for chicken
livers and hearts and
meet and legs of lamb.
He's smell it.
And restaurants in life,
you can never have it.
Milk.
Yeah,
no shit.
You're just getting seeds here.
Eat the seeds.
They have a full spectrum
of [inaudible] Polak acids.
It's all vital nutrients.
Eat the seeds.
You can get everything and just the seeds.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know.
Could you ever go vegan?
I,
I'd give it a shot.
I mean,
I wouldn't have any,
I mean just for kind of like to see how
it makes me feel and like to kind of
clean out like,
you know,
just eat and kind of raw.
I would do like raw diet or
I don't know much about it,
but I'd try like I think,
yeah I could go vegan nut fish.
I like fish too much.
I like eggs till I could
drive vegetarian cheese take.
There's some merit to vegetarian.
I think it definitely,
it probably changes your personality too.
I think it's print been a least with
anecdotal evidence proven that people we
meet are more aggressive than people who
are vegetarians kind of makes sense if
you think about just
the nature aspect of it.
Even though we're not going
out and getting the stuff,
even though we're not
killing it ourselves,
that makes sense.
We're still eating it,
you know,
we're still getting it.
You're eating flesh to the
attitude that you must have,
like the cultivating your body.
If you were a flesh eater,
a constant flesh eater,
it's gotta be a more predatory attitude.
It just makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean I don't know how the real probably
just keeps something triggered in your
body of like,
you know,
totally guessing here.
Totally talking out of my ass.
Cause obviously I don't know how the
real reward system works with like eating
meat and getting aggressive,
but we all associate like
steak with aggression.
It's like a natural association,
you know,
fucking what's a man's meall,
right.
Make sense to me.
Sold,
you know I'm doing no further research.
I'm going to repeat what you said.
Is fact the other people now I think if
we all ate shit that was like grass fed,
if we all let just grass fed beef,
there would be way less of it.
But it'd be way better for you and
people would probably enjoy it more.
But there's certainly at this point I
think there's just too many goddamn people
and not enough food,
you know,
to to live like that.
That scares me man.
I mean there are a lot of,
you know,
we would have to have monstrous,
monstrous farms to compete with some
of these crazy chicken farms will be
fucking grow them all stuffed together.
I mean everybody that,
it freaks everybody out when
you watch those chicken videos.
But if they weren't like that,
like how,
how much farm acreage would it cost?
How much more would it cost?
Is Is it at a point where we need cheap
foods so much that they have to do shit
like this?
Cause that's fucked up and I'm
not insinuating that they are.
I'm just raising the
question that is fucked up.
If that's the case,
if it's like we need to do
like the factory farming
thing cause it's fucking way
too many of us and then just sending
chickens out the moment they shit,
I'm out there fucking pop it up in the
hormones cause they gotta get a big quick
so we can ship them out to
the 300 million motherfuckers.
And out of those 300 million,
how many are farmers?
How many a 300 million people are farmers?
Is it even a million?
No,
it's not one in 301 and
300 people isn't a farmer.
Do you think there's a million
farmers in this country?
Probably say there's a different kinds of,
I don't know man.
Amelia,
either way.
Let's look at it.
Obviously folks for
you googling right now,
he's fucking guys are so
off with their numbers,
Huh?
How can I say?
All I'm trying to say is,
could you imagine if that was the case?
If it was one in every 300 could you
imagine if one person had to take care of
300 fucking people?
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
I guess,
oh no.
I would just eat a lot of
water and she'd be like,
you,
you imagine one person you
had to feed 300 people.
That's true.
One person,
one person feeds 300 people.
What the fuck?
That would be so hard.
No,
you'd have to do it by yourself.
You couldn't employ anybody.
We can employ a million
people and honor for our,
our numbers to work.
You can't employ anyone because it's
one of the 300 and we're being super
generous.
We're saying there's 1 million of farmers,
so that's,
that's where it gets fucking loony.
Toons man.
Obviously it doesn't work like that.
They have a hundred people and they do.
The work of 5,000 individuals are more,
you know,
I know obviously it
doesn't work like that,
but it almost seems
like at this point the,
the,
the resources versus population.
Isn't that a weird place where we need
an incredible amount of food and we all
sort of take for granted
that it's out there,
you know,
like who's providing all of this,
it's a lot of fucking food and if the
three of us went out right now and had
like two hours to just buy
as much food as possible,
we could each by so much fucking food.
Yeah.
It's,
to me it's like just fast food.
Like if we had like an hour or two by
is unlimited felt like we could buy
probably,
I mean
a van full.
Yeah.
More,
yeah.
250 cheeseburgers a piece.
It's just to me staggering
the way we have,
uh,
grown from being hunter gatherers to
people who lived in like small villages to
cities where we have to get the
stuff sent in every day in trucks,
just more meat for the
wheel over and over again.
Trucks and trucks of meat.
I just pump it into the city all day long
and it's really only been going on for
a few hundred years.
That's nuts,
man.
Yeah,
that's,
that's amazing.
It's almost like there's a living machine
called civilization and its blood is
animals.
I mean that's the pump you
hundred prompt alive by blood,
you know the blood and the trucks.
It's almost like individual blood cells,
you know.
But it's not,
it's a circle is much larger scale.
It's like yeah,
just meet delivery devices.
Yeah.
And that's what Keith does.
These are the,
the meat delivery devices to the city
that keeps it moving at this insane pace
where you can fit 7 million people on
one square floating place and have them
stacked on top of each other and
he just keeps sending the meat.
I saw that movie yesterday.
Did it freak you out?
All right.
It didn't really freak me out.
It,
I don't think it's stuck on a sock from,
I heard a lot of people say I liked it.
Um,
but tell me if this is right.
Does Tokyo have 36 million people?
Something crazy like that.
They're packing blew my fucking
mind cause they were talking,
you know,
like as the thing,
I mean everybody knows that.
Not that it's about a disease,
it spreads.
And they would show like,
you know,
New York population,
whatever,
8 million,
whatever lives in New York or California
or Los Angeles population is in and
they will go to Tokyo
and it said 36.4 million.
And I was like,
Eh,
that's incredible.
That's like five times the
size of the goldfish rule.
Like the bigger the bowl
of the bigger the fish.
And that's why Asians
for the most part seem,
you know,
a little bit smaller built.
And
that's interesting.
You know,
that's very interesting Brian.
That's a uh,
an interesting physiological
theory of one that,
you know,
people would consider.
It's funny if you judge
any group like that,
say a lot of Asians are small,
all of a sudden you're,
you,
you're tipping on the verge of the
swimming pool filled with racism.
Like you look right there.
What are you saying?
We say Asians are small,
but they,
their actual statistics,
you can look at like the
appetite and weight of them,
right?
They are still,
it's,
it's a weird thing if
you make an observation,
there's always the danger
of being called a racist.
Even a little observation.
It's not,
it's not at all.
Did it?
A girl from uh,
Japan and she took me on
a picnic at a dog park.
That's racist.
Yes.
Cause I'm only think
Japanese people even eat dog.
No,
but
they did.
But jokes offensive in on many levels.
Joke sucks.
Logical level.
Yeah.
The Jug makes people go,
people don't need dogs in Japan.
That's what they do.
They don't get a whole
audience full of people going,
you blow your dogs in Japan.
Yeah.
That would be the sound in the audience.
People that have dogs in Japan,
thanks.
Talks about pan
that would be accepted.
One Midwest,
yet dogs and you're paying.
I know they do.
It does make sense of what you
said because in another animals,
that is definitely the truth.
Like these guys that I know told me that
they could get me some baby crocodiles.
I had a giant fish tank and I was
looking for some exotic shit to put in my
head.
Paranas for a little while.
Oh man,
I got bored with them and I
wanted to get some crocodiles.
It seems like such a bad,
so terrible idea.
This is what I was saying.
I was saying,
okay,
well how long,
how big are these
motherfuckers going to get?
Why would I have crocodiles?
Cause we can get you crocodiles.
I go,
you can get me crocodile.
I was like,
well how big are these
crocodiles going to get?
He goes,
all,
you don't have to worry about it.
I go,
what do you mean?
He goes,
as long as the tank is small,
they won't get big.
I go,
what?
Really quiet?
No,
what?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
He said,
how big is your tank?
It was like,
I don't remember how big it was,
but it was about nine feet long.
It was a really big fish tank.
And he said,
ah,
maybe I'm exaggerating.
Seven feet long.
Oh,
that's a really big fish.
It was big.
It was very big.
He said,
don't ever get more than a few inches.
Yeah.
My uh,
my dad,
did you get them?
No.
I think they're super illegal.
And I didn't know the dude that well.
And what if he was a fucking cop,
right?
Yes.
Dot Rogan's in.
I got you some crocodiles,
brother.
My Dad,
my dad built this huge pond
in the backyard and he got
like one of those like a
hundred,
uh,
worth of,
a hundred,
like a hundred goldfish at a pet store
and I can almost feed or Goldfish,
you know,
like Shitty goldfish
throws him in the pond.
He took a couple out and put
it in this other separate pond.
The fish and the gold
upon are still alive.
A lot of them were like,
I would probably say like 20 of them
are still alive and now they're huge.
Like your monster goldfish.
The other two are normal goldfish.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
They almost look like a boy.
Well I think gold coin
goldfish are pretty related.
Yeah.
Look Related Shit.
What is with coys and tattoos?
What's that supposed to signify?
The coy becomes a dragon or some shit.
Everybody's got Koi fish.
It's Japan thing.
I think some dope ass Japan shit hands.
She's the legend.
They figured out tattooing.
They figured out how
to make like a sleeve.
They're the ones who first figured
that shit out really to make like big,
big,
bold pieces.
You know,
like the old days,
you have a Koi fish?
No,
I don't have any Koi fish.
I do have a drag and
though tiger in a Samurai.
How long ago?
A lot of Japanese shit.
This one's six years old and
this one's two years old.
Oh,
you had that all done at the same time?
Yeah.
This dude Aaron Dellavedova
from Guru Tattoo in San Diego.
He's a fucking bad ass artist.
And um,
I just,
uh,
I just always enjoyed tattoos.
I always liked him.
I think you're wearing
some cool art on your skin,
you know,
and there's a lot of people
attach a lot of weird shit to it.
Like you don't have to do it.
But to me,
like I take care of my body and
I'm a healthy and everything,
but I'm want to decorate it
the way I want to give a fuck.
For some people it's a,
it's a weird thing.
So weirds mountain tattoos,
weird amount tattoos,
weird people out because
they're permanent.
You know when you have tattoos it's like
he's willing to do something permanent
being that some dumb tattoos we got,
I have Ozzie rules tattooed on my toes.
Do you really?
Are you serious?
Before Ozzie came back like it was,
that's weird.
How old were you when you got that?
26 I was waiting to hear 33 26 27 and uh,
but it was before the Osbornes and stuff.
Like it was like,
yeah.
Yeah,
it was me and my friend
were talking about we watch
done it or were you disappointed
once the Osbornes came out?
Were you like fuck man,
now it's mainstream?
Um,
not really.
I mean it's on my toes,
but it definitely made the joke like
not funny anymore cause you used to see
like Ozzy written bathroom stall.
I used to see Ozzy rules
written everywhere.
Right,
right.
And he just didn't see it
anymore and I was like,
Ozzy still fucking rules man.
Like we saw this interview with him
on like VH one behind the music,
me and my friend.
And they asked Ozzy what
the key to happiness was.
And Ozzy said the key to
happiness is appy knees.
And they were like,
what?
And he's like,
API knees.
The key to happiness is API knees.
And I like what?
What are you talking about?
He stands up and pulls his down and he's
got smiley faces tattooed on his knees
and he goes,
appy knees happy knees wide.
I thought it was funny.
I was like,
Ozzy rules man.
Funny.
Not Funny enough to laugh.
It's like funny loves to smile.
I Dunno man.
Ozzie was pretty,
he's a pretty funny character.
He did a lot of crazy shit.
It's amazing.
He's still alive,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I mean he's one of those
dudes because they're like,
wow,
he made it through.
Uh,
yeah.
And now he's like this mainstream.
Like,
did you ever think you'd see Ozzy
Osborne doing like a fucking,
I don't know.
He's didn't like,
I'm sort of a thing with his wife
and his kids on TV commercials too.
You see them in pretty
mainstream commercial.
Really like fucking,
yeah,
for like direct TV and shit.
It's weird.
Or like cars.
Probably,
I don't know.
I don't really pay
attention as we get older,
say things.
You know,
as we get older we're more willing to do
take shit from crazy people that
we like than we ever were before.
You know,
like look this Chris Brown dude who,
Oh yeah,
you got that reality check.
He sort of making a comeback,
you know,
and it's like all these award shows
and Shit and apparently he's a super
talented,
a great singer and there's some people
that are accepting it and some people
not.
And like look at this Micheal Veck thing.
Michael Vick killed a bunch
of dogs and his back plan it,
you can't tell me this is the same world
that I grew up in because this is a
different world.
This is a different world.
People are stranger world.
People are getting away with more
people are more forgiving because more
people are fucking up and doing weird or
creepy or shit because of
the Internet and stuff.
Man,
the bar is going higher and
higher doing more deviant shit.
So they're like,
well,
let's not be so hard on that
guy because I don't know,
maybe I want to fucking try some
of that weird shit or whatever.
Don't you think that people have bounced
back from Shit that they could've never
bounced back from before?
You know,
sports I,
yeah.
I think Michael Vick is definitely
something that wouldn't have happened 25
years ago.
I'm shocked.
But I mean,
when you're that like,
yeah,
I think the morals of the,
our entire cultures have just
been eroded a little bit.
Like,
yeah,
I don't think that would
have been acceptable in the,
in the early eighties like it would,
it's,
it's also fun.
You have a guide that talented to who can,
you know?
But yeah,
I just,
I don't,
I don't think money overrode everything
25 years ago.
Could you imagine if
Clinton was in office today?
Oh Man.
Jim Magic Twitter messages that like
interns would be throwing back and forth
because he would get busted for
sure if it was an office today.
Yeah.
I think about the crazy shit that dude did
so many more avenues of him.
Like a,
he was always my,
my proof.
You know,
like when,
when he got his dick sucked by that check,
I was always like,
God damn it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I knew they have to be
crazy to get in there.
You can't really be that
guy you're selling man.
You can't,
you're not going to have the kind of
[inaudible] likes blowjobs though,
man.
Yeah,
yeah.
Everybody explode exposures.
But Clinton would just whip
his dick out on people.
He would just get alone with girls.
Just whip his dick out
cause he got out of control.
He was a maniac.
He's a fucking savage who got blossom.
Just one of those dudes just
couldn't help it swaying.
I can't help a swine.
I saw the pitch.
There comes,
he just loved it.
Yeah.
I mean there were a lot of
chicks doing that to him.
Could you imagine if
he existed during the,
you know,
the days of Wiener Gate?
Fuck yeah.
It could have been set up.
I bet he liked Geraldo.
I bet he likes to get drunk
and Bang State troopers,
hot police troopers.
How hot would not be in
the back of a police car.
That's a lot of girls.
A lot of girls.
I bet.
I bet it's pussy output tripled after
that Monica Lewinsky thing because there's
a lot of girls that just want to let
him know and then keep their mouth shut.
Listen,
I know you had that problem with Monica,
but you know when she's a little
girl and it's not me and I'm,
I'm a grown woman and I wanted to want
what I want to do and I don't need
anything other than you and my
mouth and that's the end of it.
And he blew it.
He was just dropping
loads on dresses and shit.
He wasn't even and assistant,
she'd get rid of the evidence.
Maybe this could make people in
another part of the world is my DNA.
We can't have that.
Yeah,
he was a freak though.
Stuck in the fucking
cigars and bitches pussy.
I don't know if it was
a good president round.
I don't know.
Maybe when he was in,
he was when he was on the show.
The writers had it
written in a more happy,
friendly Wa and I thought you were
insinuating he did your podcasts,
your,
you imagine he was on the show,
get him on the show.
I am the President for eight years,
dad.
And it was a,
for the most part laughs.
Good guy in there.
I mean there's only been though Buzzy,
I don't know.
No,
Obama is probably a good guy.
I don't know if any of them are good guys.
I don't,
I'm not sure what I'm going to do
anything fucked up shit to get that far.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't think you could be
just some regular fucking
dude with some unique ideas
and get all the way to be president.
You have to have compromise
yourself so deeply along the lines.
And obviously I've done no research
whatsoever to substantiate any of these
claims and stuff.
This is just talking shit at 10 o'clock
in the evening after being in the hot
sun all day and barely able to talk.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't believe it though.
Do you believe that like a
good guy can make it this far?
Now do you think you have to say,
do they ultimately agreed to letting
unspeakable things happen on the regular?
I mean,
you have to,
I want to say anything.
You just think,
oh,
it'd be even rewrite the script.
Everyone entity.
A lot of people don't
believe that that's the case.
A lot of people believe that
it was Lee Harvey Oswald
and he got lucky and that people
make a big deal out of nothing.
Yeah,
maybe.
I mean,
I,
you know,
Kennedy,
Martin Luther King,
both Kennedy,
I mean it just seems like anybody who's
kind of like steering us towards some
decent change winds up with their
fucking head blown off by a fucking crazy
gunman.
Even John Lennon Dude,
like,
I mean,
that could have started a revolution.
He was like,
the web isn't a popular guy
is,
it is.
It's so tempting to fall into the idea
of conspiracy and collusion and it's very
sexy.
It's very tempting.
But I mean there's no,
it doesn't seem like there's
balance on the other side.
Like,
why didn't Nixon ever gets shot?
Or like,
I mean Reagan did.
I guess that's a,
you mean balance on the [inaudible]?
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
You know,
he was one of the most raw raw wall,
but like,
I dunno,
it seems like,
you know Gandhi like yours.
No.
Well Shane,
he didn't never got fucking shot
at because he was on team psycho.
And is it possible that the psychos on,
they're always going to be four tab?
Yeah,
they target the guys who are for
peace and love and change course.
They went after Reagan.
I wonder.
Reagan might have been
been,
maybe that was a random thing.
Maybe that really wasn't planned because
he didn't die or maybe they're just
sending them a message.
Shoot you in the Gulch and
watching that on TV going,
God damn,
they shot that actor dude
as now the president,
somebody has a joke.
It was a little kid.
You know,
him and Leslie,
like if he never became president,
he would have the same career
that Leslie Nielsen had.
I forget who
fucking joke it is.
Oh,
that's brilliant.
So true.
Bedtime for Bonzo.
Did you ever see that?
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm an engineer with a monkey.
Yeah.
He did.
A couple wasn't there?
There's a couple of bonds.
Oh,
movies aren't there?
I think so.
I Dunno.
I never watched like five
seconds of it and go,
what the fuck is anything
more than one monkey movie?
It just shouldn't be legal that if
you're a person who is a professional
pretender that you go on to be the
guy who tells the truth to the nation.
That just seems ridiculous.
Well,
you're awesome at lying.
Yeah.
Well,
it was just like,
I don't think now him,
I don't think he made one decision and
the whole time I think there were people,
there was like Dick Cheney
was telling him what to say.
Look,
there was a commission of
fucking assholes who were like,
all right,
this is what we're doing.
Here's the script.
You're an actor,
act.
You know what I'd love to make?
Loves him out through the door.
He's responsible for one little speech.
That is one of my favorite speeches of
any president because he talks about how
would we respond if we were all on
this earth facing a threat from another
world.
You know,
how would we respond?
How quickly would we
forget our differences?
And I'm like,
damn,
that's brilliant.
It's so true.
It's a great speech and it makes you go,
what the fuck does he know?
Well,
yeah.
What was he really into
the fucking Star Wars Shit.
Like he wanted to make that,
you know,
that missile defense system start
like maybe the aliens who were like,
Hey man,
we're going to fuck with you guys soon.
I don't know.
Who knows what's going on with all that.
George Lucas during
the star wars thing go,
hey,
this is copyright and friends.
Did He,
what,
why were they allowed to
car wars program program?
Um,
I guess because they're not,
they're allowed to do anything want,
I don't know their government,
but they're not doing it for like profit.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a defense.
there's a,
uh,
um,
some big conspiracy theory about people
who created star wars that the strategic
defense system,
Star Wars,
yeah.
That it was all bullshit and that the
scientists one by one had been killed off
apparently 22 different scientists who
worked on it were killed in a strange
ways.
He's serious.
His Fist reation suffocation,
decapitation death leap,
death leave,
shotgun blast,
missing person auto accident
over and over again.
All these different scientists.
I don't want this coordinate
according to the Internet.
Oh,
operated by more than,
listen man,
I didn't at first thing I
went to on Google did start.
I'm going to regurgitate that as fact.
Just go for it.
20 to 22 Sdi researchers all
supposedly 22 out of how many out?
It's a good question,
but 22 periods.
A lot.
Let's say if there's a hundred
comedians started dying,
like I'd fucking skipped town.
Yeah,
that'd be gross.
Would be hundreds.
How many people you would
think that would be,
what if they,
uh,
if they did that,
if they started killing comedian?
Yeah.
Oh,
I was just saying if 22 comedians
died in suspicious ways,
I would fucking,
you know,
that's a,
that's too big of a number for one.
But I've out of all the,
we'll get a puppet immediately out of
all the scientists that were involved in
it.
I'm sorry,
my question was do you think
there was like 300 guys?
Like how many different guys do you
think were working for this star wars
company?
Was it a thousand people
with lives and yeah,
I would say that even if it sounds that
would be from this janitor wanting to
kill themselves while oh yeah.
Or just disappear.
As the number becomes bigger and bigger,
it becomes more and more silly.
You start looking at and go,
well there was a million scientists,
22 killed themselves.
A bunch of them.
Like there wouldn't be that
many that had like crazy.
Not everybody has like
crazy security levels.
Like you would have to kill everybody.
Like every guy gets screwed
in a fucking light bulb.
You would though.
Cause maybe what was going
on was so fucking obvious.
You had a clean house.
This is the conspiracy
theory during me most
step back and do my Alex
Jones voice we've got,
here's a situation where special ops,
what they're doing is they're
victimizing innocent people.
That's fucking good,
man.
Thank you.
I mean,
did you hear them all?
100% of the signs created
crystal Pepsi Guide.
Shut the fuck.
Uh,
could you imagine if that is true?
That what if there,
I mean we're,
we're,
we know there's 22 scientists that died.
We need to find out how many
there were making a documentary.
Did you hear about a
hydro collider thing?
That guy I should go to Snopes for all
of this is what I should do then is the
guy that might be a need from the future.
Arrested at the collider.
Uh,
last week.
Yeah.
Some guy was arrested at the,
what's it called?
The hydrogen large Hadron Collider.
Yeah.
He was arrested because I don't know why,
what he was doing,
but he was said he was
from the future dummy.
Oh,
that's funny.
Was he just crazy or was he from,
I don't know.
I just thought it headline.
What a goofy fuck.
That'd be so that's a funny idea.
Show up there and a silver suit.
You just have to ask him a few more
questions and there'll be pretty clear.
Oh,
you come from in the future.
Okay.
What am I right to?
There was one guy with a website.
There was a fuck,
I forget the um,
the scam g two t tour somewhere.
I think they were calling themselves
something t tour from the future and yet
they have this whole John [inaudible],
t I t u r and some whole thing about how
he described how the civilization was
going to fall apart and he had come from
the future to write and get the fuck
out,
man.
Stop John t toward whatever it is.
It's just,
you really think that someone came from
the fucking future and came back to the
past.
You really think that it's just,
that's what time travel's
going to be alike.
Yeah,
it was Nicholas Cage.
You see that shit.
Now they're saying that,
that,
that Nicholas cage is a time traveler
because there's a photo or something like
John crew sack bro.
Huh?
Not they have Nicolas Cage.
They have John Cusack cause he,
he never looked at the older,
oh,
you know,
I'm sorry.
No,
not even John Cusack.
The other dude from the Matrix,
Keanu Reeves,
Yana Reeves cannot reuse.
They have him at the time machine.
They're always saying that he's a vampire.
Ever gets old.
Yeah.
He's beautiful man.
It's like 50 depths holding up.
Okay.
If he's holding up pretty good.
Good,
good.
Both have kind of Indian blood,
fresh pussy like vampires,
the pussy that's constantly
swan diving under their cock.
Every time they poke it
out the house for some air,
put it through their mail slot and it
goes cage might be a vampire or so,
one believer says,
oh,
photo,
I'm from an old ass photo
that looks like Nicholas Cage.
It's creepy.
Wow.
That's pretty dope.
I was removed.
He's in a most powerful empires kiss.
That's pretty funny.
The ghost rider,
Bro.
Did you see ghost writers saw that?
No.
It's terrible,
but it's good if you're high and you know,
it's terrible if you're like ready for
a terrible fucking ghost motorcycle
superhero movie.
Yeah.
You have little girls,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
did you ever watch the
tooth fairy with the rock?
The tooth fairy to rock?
Yeah.
No,
I missed that one.
That's a,
I watched that man.
Why did you watch that?
Because it was like late.
I took mushrooms with my and uh,
and it was just that kind of like after
we're done tripping but we're still
like,
you know,
up and hanging out and that was
coming on Hbr and we're like fuck it,
let's watch it.
It's probably good for a few laughs.
And we had to,
uh,
we had to rewind it like 40 minutes
in because we couldn't follow what
was going on.
Like it's baffling.
Like there's so many holes in it.
Like he has this
relationship with this woman,
but you don't know if they're
married and there's these kids,
it's weird,
like you don't know his
relationship to the,
it's not his wife and kids,
but like he's hanging around there
and he never kisses the woman
and,
and then he somehow like,
it's never really clear on why
he turns into a tooth fairy.
Like he said,
something like that,
the tooth fairy is bullshit
bullshitted kid like at one point.
And then all of a sudden he's like in
this weird tooth fairy land and he's got
to be very,
it's kind of like,
it's,
it sounds awesome.
And then Billy crystal makes an
appearance and I totally called it like,
because he like goes through
tooth fairy training,
you know,
learning how to fly all fucking
bumping into the tooth fairy training.
Well yeah,
it's like,
yeah,
you know,
where's tooth fairy land in his brain?
He probably just got hit
on the head or something.
And this was all in his head.
That was really the plot.
Yeah.
And then he turns into the tooth fairy
and uh,
and then like we were
watching it and it's like,
and I was like,
all right,
Billy,
Billy Crystal's old Jew characters
going to make an appearance or what be
Goldberg or like somebody like that.
And then fucking right there,
Billy crystal comes down this ladder like,
okay,
hold your horses,
hold you.
And he gives him some books
on how to be a tooth fairy.
And,
and then he like turns into the
tooth fairy randomly like ob,
it,
uh,
you know,
out in public in this
wings just spurt out.
I feel like I'm losing momentum
trying to get it.
You've got me in a trend
is you got me in a trance.
That sounds ridiculous.
It's really absurd,
but when you have kids,
you understand ridiculous.
Keeps quiet,
man.
It keeps moving,
but there's no,
there aren't a lot of dots connected.
We were like,
wait,
how do we get from here?
It's like,
oh,
you just needed to get from here to here.
So you just put some thing in the middle.
Yeah.
It's really like,
now I'm going to see it
to be waiting for that.
I wonder.
We're waiting for the whole,
Oh,
it's renal.
You doing something.
I'm trying to open
another root beer barrel,
but I can't figure out how you
silly silly dad can't figure.
We got to change these microphones.
These microphones are too.
God Damn sensitive.
You're doing a down by your deck and we
were hearing it as if cracklin resume.
I know.
Sorry.
These are the bags.
The volcano bags I gave
up on that volcano.
Well,
most people shouldn't be trying
to open up our candy during a,
what'd you say,
Brian?
That that kind of Mike
would be worse though.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Cause these are,
you're supposed to talk into it.
These are picking up every,
here we go.
That does at times a million.
No,
no,
no.
It's less.
That's less Brian.
Those are more vocal miles.
Yeah,
it's less.
No,
we tried it.
Remember it picked up
way less ambient noise.
That's our next move.
As we expand,
we're going to move this thing out into,
I'm going to get an office
space at the Ice House.
Right?
Well,
we've got to do that too.
We've got to do that too.
But what we're to do with the ice houses,
we want to set it up so the comics getting
offstage and going onstage can have a
little different podcasts,
not my podcast,
but we're going to call it like
an evening at the ice house.
Right.
Habits.
Just whatever comic is there,
you know,
within reason they hosted or whatever.
They just figured out.
It's just the reserve.
Yeah.
Brian's in town.
He'll,
he'll,
he'll sit on it.
Whoever the fuck is in town and
we just keep rotating comics.
Like get off sick.
Yeah,
it'd be awesome.
It'd be great for all of us.
That'll be a lot of fun.
That whole night with this stuff that
you and hour talking about siding.
It's great,
right?
We want to go there.
There's a place,
the ice house in Pasadena,
it's this really cool old club.
It's been around for like 35 years
and they have this little tiny room.
They just have like the 50th anniversary.
That's insane.
50 smothers brothers and
shit performed there.
There are a lot of albums recorded there,
like if you're at a thrift store
and go through old comedy albums,
that's amazing.
Pat's hall.
It's a great,
great club and there's two rooms.
She was the big room,
which is very small.
It's only 185 people and then there's the,
or somewhere around there,
right?
One 85 one 97 was a perfect
size room by the way.
Amazing set up.
It's amazing setup and then there's
another room is really small.
It's only like 85 people,
90 people.
And we,
we've been doing that.
We've been doing subsets there
and Brendan and I and Brian,
Brian and one Friday out,
magical came down and already went up.
And you guys have one this Friday?
Every Friday.
Yeah.
And uh,
we're,
we're going to start doing that on a
regular basis and as soon as I'm done with
this fear factor stuff,
which should be pretty soon,
then we're going to move forward in
different dynamic podcast directions.
So we'll call it a,
an evening at the ice house or something
along those lines we ever talked about
that.
Remember when we brought up how David
Letterman social security number was on
the wall and we went
there the following day.
Yeah.
We don't know whether or not that really
is still his social security number.
Will they change it?
Like it got out there,
they put it back up,
they block it out.
They made a copy of it and it looks like
the idea that they're real one or they
did something.
It's gone now though.
Well,
we,
we pointed it out to them.
We're like,
you know,
you can see David Letterman social
security number on this contract.
And they were like,
no way.
Like yeah,
there's a picture of his contract.
Yeah,
we paid him.
Oh,
okay.
Near the bathroom.
A couple of different ones.
Yeah.
And that one actually has a
social security number on it.
That's insane.
It's ridiculous.
Steals identity.
Well that's what Brian or he did.
He's trying to like,
like viruses and shit.
Like how I assume anybody
who knows anything about
computers can hack and all my
shit.
Cause I don't know anything.
I'm really naive.
I could do dumb shit,
just trache shit.
But there's kids right now that are
growing up from the time they're little
kids.
They've been fucking with hacking into
the registry and fucking with things and
reading on forums and finding out how
to do things and working on coding.
And there's wizards out there,
man.
I know they speak a language.
We can't even
fucking wrap our heads around.
There was a documentary on one small area,
I think it was a rush out.
I forget what eastern bloc country it was,
what they had.
Um,
this,
uh,
one town where they have
a disproportionate amount
of internet scammers and
virus makers and people stealing
credit card numbers in there.
We're all just drive in
Mercedes back at Fraley.
Yeah.
All these computer people,
they just fucking hack the matrix.
Found like,
uh,
an area like we're oil would come up
drilled into it and the oil was coming up
in there one spot.
Ah,
it's amazing,
you know.
Wow.
I told just identity theft and shit and
it was a lot of that going on for sure.
There's a lot of,
I mean,
cyber crime.
I would like to know
the statistics of what,
you know,
what has happened since
the Internet existed.
Like it's crime up as crime down.
What kind of crime is more
prevalent now that there's a,
you know,
little online things
that can rip people off?
Yeah.
Probably some,
like,
I don't know.
You're not leaving a paper trail,
if anything.
So if you just go in and move
numbers from one place to him,
it just would scare the fucking shit
out of me to think that you would have
anything important on why,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm pretty,
I mean,
I guess that's one good thing
of not really being a techie.
Like I don't get excited about,
I don't have anything.
Somebody could steal my laptop tomorrow
and they wouldn't really know any more
about me than if they
stole one of my notebook.
Yeah.
I always look at websites
that are up and I said,
these are only up because
someone didn't target you.
That's it.
Right.
It's not like,
oh,
I could do anything about it.
What are you going to do about it?
You're not gonna do shit.
It's like there's a,
it's a wild west out there in some ways.
I mean,
they can track some people down if they're
really sloppy and they find out the
people that do certain things
that shouldn't be doing,
but for the most part it's,
it's pretty fucking crazy,
you know?
Well,
those guys like the anonymous
and who laws sec those like they,
I was pretty amused by
what they were doing.
Scary where it's like,
oh fuck.
It's like if they can fuck
with Sony for like a week,
what could they do to meet their,
putting some of those
dudes in jail though.
It'd be like,
well that's the other thing
you're going to get fucking,
you don't get away with that kind of shit.
This is going to be like
a government agencies.
It's going to be a bad ass documentary
that we'll be able to watch and like 10
years.
Like if you ever watched a documentary
on the weather underground.
Yeah,
I saw radical hippie movement and
the sixties wanted to get rid of the
government and it's fascinating
fucking documentary.
That's what this is going to be like.
You know,
a decade from now when
we're even more oppressed,
we'll look back at the time that the
internet and it almost rose before the
Institute of the
censorship on the Internet,
that would really lock everything down.
That would either lock everything
down or cause a civil war.
It'd be that would be the final push.
If the government regulated the Internet,
the way the FCC regulates television or
the way they regulate radio or anything.
If they're like told you what,
you couldn't,
couldn't put out that Ooh,
because that's where
it all got out of hand.
Everything was doing great until the
and the nineties came along and all of a
sudden people were getting their
information from different places.
They were getting it from a fucking
computer with that Wiki leaks guy.
I mean,
aren't they essentially like,
it's like you can't really put whatever
you want out there while they lock that
guy up and they gave that guy
some sort of a house arrest deal.
We had a show up at the police station
and check himself in every day.
And from what I understand,
he's trying to fight,
being extradited.
He doesn't want to have
to leave the country,
but I don't,
I have no idea what the fuck happened.
But I do think that,
I don't believe that this would
happen this way if he wasn't that guy.
I think it seems pretty obvious
it's someone's targeting him.
Oh yeah,
it doesn't,
doesn't seem kosher.
There may,
you know that this what I mean,
I don't believe she's even
saying it was really rape.
It was by some really
broad definition of rape,
like regret afterwards
or something like that.
The feeling of being deceived
or something along those lines,
you know,
changed her mind.
Like how when he was
finishing up or whatever,
something along those lines.
Right.
And he was already inside of
her and he didn't want to stop.
There's already like on the run like he
was already wanted and you know when all
that happened I thought wasn't.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's just fascinating how,
how you know you're not allowed to
release information and less your,
the New York Times or CNN or,
or an established news organizations
slash corporation that we can trust.
You're not allowed to just release that.
So because like the,
the real question would come up with what
would the New York Times do if it was
given that information.
If it was given all the
wikileaks documents,
if someone came along and said,
listen,
here's a gigantic file.
You're going to fucking shit your pants.
This is all a bunch of
shit that I took from,
you know,
US data banks and it's going to,
it's going to blow the whole on this
whole Iraq war thing and there's a lot of
things in it.
It's going to really disturb the shit
out of people when they find out about
real relationships between
different foreign countries
and different things that
we're doing and all sorts of
different parts of the world.
What do you think,
what happened?
I don't think that would get
released through a a real thing.
The New York Times would go,
get the fuck out of here.
We're not releasing this.
Probably could give it
back to the government,
I think.
Yeah,
there was,
it wasn't their property
is that there's a,
is that a law?
I think that they're dealing
with like a business,
so we don't want to fuck it.
Would it be stolen information?
So there it would be illegal contraband
or something along those lines because
it's top secret.
I think the government would
just come and confiscate it.
Somebody would call somebody
and the government and be like,
you have a lot or sending someone
right down and then just like,
does that ever going to change?
Is that ever going to get to the point
where that doesn't happen anymore?
Is that like a remnant of the old days?
That's like slowly starting to work its
way out to the point where you know it's
police aren't going to have like
that kind of absolute power.
Is that possible?
Uh,
I don't think so.
Really?
No.
It's gonna get worse.
Right?
Is it get worse like the future,
you know,
if you like,
if you want a picture of the future,
imagine a boot standing on
somebody's neck forever.
Something like that.
Oh,
Orwell's bitch rag I was Orwell to you
are fucking killing me with this boot and
neck thing.
Why don't you just go to a massage parlor?
You know,
just a wonderful feeling of
warm oil on your balls and just,
ah,
just sweet release.
You don't have to think
about x well needed.
It's not all boots and next you
fucking dramatic cock sucker.
I mean,
he wrote animal farm in 1984 oh,
he's brilliant.
Like the forties when I
say dramatic cock sucker,
I mean it was all due respect.
He,
he actually predicted a lot
of shit that went down that,
you know,
is essentially science
fiction at the time.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
You know,
amazing Internet essentially.
I mean you could argue that,
you know,
that screen that everybody had in their
apartments in 1984 1984 supposed to be
the year where this,
this story took place.
Is that what the premises,
isn't it amazing when you look back like
on space 1999 they thought that by 1999
and we'd be like fucking
living on other planets.
Yeah.
Thousand 10
you know,
2010 was the year they made contact.
Right.
In 2001 a space odyssey.
That's like 2010 they thought this
is ridiculously far in the future.
This is so far in the future that we're
never going to have to worry about that.
We'll just make our money now and we'll
probably be right when 2001 Roosevelt,
nothing.
No,
no fucking space travel at all.
I don't know though,
man.
Like I,
I was at,
that's the one area though where we
grossly overestimated how far we would
advance space truthers unmanned
space shit out there and the shore.
But there's this space station
with people on it right now,
but space in 98 99 they
were living on fucking,
there were shows like
Jetson's cars and yeah,
I mean why didn't they have battles
with like other like fucking aliens and
Shit?
I'm pretty sure they did probably.
Oh yeah,
no,
that was the future.
That's a prince song bitch.
What's a ridiculous space in 1999
those smart cars are pretty futuristic
looking.
Well,
you know Obama just passed some
new legislation saying that by,
I think it's 2025 that the
average miles per gallon of a car,
it has to be some insane number.
It's like 50 plus miles per gallon and
that's what's going to be the standard
average per corporation.
Like you could have one stupid car.
They're like,
you can have one Mustang gt with a
fucking giant engine that eats gas.
As long as you had a
slew of electric cars,
got like 90 miles to the gallon and
sort of balanced it out for the most,
like,
yeah.
It's kind of interesting.
But did you ever see that documentary
who killed the electric car?
Yes,
I did.
Oh,
it was pretty interesting.
Fascinating.
I mean,
they had a pretty decent electric
carts back in [inaudible] 86
yeah,
and then they reap.
They just took them all and destroy them.
That's fishy.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
conspiracies are real man,
you know,
and on the smartest men in the room.
Do you ever watch that documentary?
Can conspiracies are fucking real.
Okay.
Yeah,
they definitely went to war because I'm
looking on space 1999 and Wikipedia is
that a show is shooting lasers at them?
Yeah.
Space 1999 you didn't
know that was a show.
I thought maybe it was like,
oh,
what I was saying that it was a show
that I used to watch when I was a kid.
Oh No,
I thought it was fine.
It was a moderate on that and oh my God,
the idea really was,
they were so optimistic.
This is how crazy they work.
Cause we had just gone to the moon,
you know,
supposedly,
and it's 1975 so did they just stop the
Apollo program and 72 so in 1999 they
thought we would be fucking going to war,
but there was only 20 years.
There were only guessing.
2124 years in the future,
24 years.
They thought,
we'll dude,
we finally landed on the moon.
Remember when we invented cars?
Now look what what we drive.
They finally ended up in the moon.
Listen Dude,
by the time 1999 rolls around,
we're going to be going
to battle and space.
It's fucking people who
are living in uniforms.
They had outfits and shit like that
was the other hallmark of the future.
Everybody wore the same clothes.
That's how you knew it was the future.
Future or aliens.
You know,
they're all wearing the same clothes.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean Walmart,
I know that that is a fascinating thing.
Matching silver jumpsuits.
Most people were getting their
clothes from the same four places,
probably old navy.
It's amazing that they missed so badly.
1999 they were so optimistic,
you know,
2001 so optimistic.
Know a lot of things.
Got It right though.
That,
that old a ride at Walt Disney world.
Uh,
you know,
the,
in the future where it was like a thing
where you just sat there and watched
like the,
what the future is supposed to be like,
if you look at it now,
it's pretty,
pretty crazy.
How similarity do you remember alien?
You remember
Strauma when they're,
when they're in their ship and
he's working on the computer,
it looks so fucking bad.
Oh yeah.
It's funny.
I love that when Shit computer,
you have a piece of shit with
it's green fucking letters.
It's green lit up letters.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Look so stupid in the printer paper
still has the holes on the side of
the year 3000 out.
He didn't even have a cell phone.
Right.
He had walkie talkies within the
stromal the fucking computer.
Man.
They missed so badly.
But there's like now we're at
a point where we can imitate.
You predict things a little like I think,
you know,
it seems like a lot of crews.
What was that minority or that shit
sort of shit and other movies too.
So maybe that's the
way things were headed.
When I swiped my iPhone,
when I'm going through like contacts
or when I'm going through a email,
I think I think of it that way.
Like this is amazing.
These things are amazing.
Sliding this thing back
and forth with my fingers.
And then iPads,
the same thing.
I read books,
the IPAD and
we haven't turned the page.
Just slowly slide your finger and slowly
curls the page over and then enrolls in
the next page.
Like,
Whoa,
this is,
this is some freaky fucking futuristic
shit and we're getting it right.
Yeah.
Now like I went to a concert a couple
of weeks ago and you just look,
I went to smoke a cigarette and was
like looking at the whole crowd in the
Hollywood bowl and you just see
all these little light up things.
Yeah.
And it's like,
that's kind of crazy man.
Like it,
it happens so quickly.
Really 10 years ago you didn't see,
I was typing an email today and I was
on the iPhone and I f I just was just
thinking about how crazy it is and I
could just touch these little spots,
knows pretty much what
letter you're trying to say.
And then you can just swipe your finger
and it's spins through all your pictures
and spins through all your music.
Like this is nuts man.
This is so specific to its so like
Joe,
you got God to try out
this thing called Spotify.
It's kind of like rhapsody city.
It's an all you can eat any kind of music,
you know for $10 you get
all the music you want.
Pretty much thing.
So for $10 one time fee,
no,
every month,
$10 a month,
$10 a month.
I mean he was,
but you sit there and you just have access
to pretty much any song ounces mine.
But it is,
I don't really understand
the service but yeah,
you can like $10 a month.
You could put it in like rolling stones
and every rolling stones song will come
up and you can download.
But what's called,
what's cool is it whoever has
it connected to their Facebook,
like a lot of your friends,
like Dunkin is a good example is you're
going to see his whole entire music,
like what he likes,
what he listens to.
So you can just like,
if you're looking for new music
is basically what it takes.
And he just like,
look at all this music.
It's pretty cool.
I would try it out.
You can download their music too and you
could also download it onto your phone
and has that album.
I want it.
And you can put it on an iPhone.
He put it on an iPod and you kill
what the thing is the Spotify,
it's like your iTunes,
but it's held at some servers in a way.
But I think there's a way
to also download the tracks.
So like if you have offline mode,
so like if you just pick
what things you want,
it'll download the
tracks onto your iPhone.
That's annoying.
I would want to,
I don't,
I'm Todd.
I wanted on my hard drive.
I want a physical,
I think you can do that.
Really?
Yeah.
I think once you do that,
yeah you can put it on
your download or your iPad.
Your phone doesn't have to be
connected to the Internet to use it.
Uh,
no,
you could download it.
You have to be connected to
the Internet at some point.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
To get it right.
Right.
But you just like refreshing it just,
it just saves it onto your device
and it is just like downloading it
to a CD and I think I might have
some kind of a time like fit.
It only lasts a certain amount of time,
like it has really see,
oh no,
no,
no.
I think that's how it works.
Did I think it has to check for
subscription once in a while or something?
Oh,
that's annoying.
But uh,
so as long as your prescriptions up,
but you know,
it's good to get a car
driving around going.
It's all annoying
man.
When you got it,
you got it right.
I,
I keep an iPhone or an
iPod always charged up.
I always listened to in my car.
I hardly ever listen to the radio anymore.
I just listen to my Ipod,
know connects to my car.
It's fucking,
it's amazing.
You can just choose whatever music,
but all I have to do is just like sync
it back and forth between my computers.
I don't want to go home and then just
fucking register and pay 10 bucks a month.
I buy the CD on Itunes,
I buy the mp3s.
That's good for me.
I don't want any of that craziness.
I have satellite in my car and I like it
because I've been turned onto a lot of
new music that I wouldn't have heard.
There's one station in particular like
I like that and d kind of rock shit.
I like what type of road shit?
Like indie,
like I like nineties
Indie rock a lot and like,
you know like pavement,
Shit like that.
Sing me a song.
Ah,
well I mean,
I don't know like dinosaur jr
you familiar with any of that?
I wasn't in the scene.
A radio station wantsW ,
a f and Boston and um,
the,
uh,
one of the dudes from dinosaur Jr,
what does it Maskus what does it say?
Mass Mass just sang a song like right
there and it was a real creepy like
acoustic song.
And I'm like,
wow,
what a weird dude this guy is.
I bet this guy.
Some fucking crazy,
creepy,
weird genius dude.
They are,
I mean that's a certain genre.
Um,
like uh,
well like Nirvana came out of that too.
Yeah.
It's like the Melvins and fucking right,
but is nirvana,
if you talk about like that
kind of music you want,
that you like,
if you say Nirvana,
did they think,
oh,
you're all mainstream?
Um,
no,
because I mean their vinyl like
naturally happened that came from like,
they want it to be as big as sonic
youth or dinosaur junior and just,
they just wrote songs way too
good and fucking just got huge.
They reinvented things.
Hey,
change the format,
everything they fucked hairbands
and vanilla ice and MC Hammer.
Those guys were big ox.
I owned it on.
But yeah,
like where'd this come from?
Is All this truth and pain and reality.
Dude screaming,
rape me,
raped me again.
It's a great song.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
rape me is a great fucking song.
And it played on the radio.
You know,
just,
just wrap your head around that.
Imagine trying to put that out today.
Rape me.
A song called rape me.
People would freak the fuck out.
They wouldn't want to
play that on the radio.
Too many people would be complaining.
This guy went on stage or
a in the UFC this weekend,
uh,
there was a controversy.
This,
um,
these two fighters went out to a
controversial songs and one of them was,
he went out to smack my bitch up.
Okay.
And so this writer was
complainants that that was,
yes,
they wrote an article and Yahoo about
how it was insensitive to have that song.
And that song promotes violence
against women and Jess,
that people might find it offensive.
And then the other son they complained
about was the scorpions rocky,
like a hurricane.
Because obviously we're in
New Orleans and New Orleans,
but meanwhile you watch them two
guys beating the shit out of each
other and when that song came on,
I don't think people
thought that I didn't,
that I didn't even,
I didn't even assume that
action until I read the article.
Conti little writer fucking
monitor cause a stir.
Do you know how funny it is?
And you just said that cause I got in
trouble for calling is very writer Conti.
Really?
Yeah.
People are like,
you shouldn't use that word.
Sounds like content.
I didn't,
I did not inform you of this beforehand.
We had no discussion.
There was no coercion on your part.
Nope.
Ladies and gentlemen,
nature finds its fucking course.
She'll the other one was the,
the scorpions.
Rocky like a hurricane.
When I heard that song I didn't think,
oh no he did.
And a hurricane hit here and
devastated the population.
That's just thought.
I thought,
oh it was a fucking jam.
Yeah.
That's a good thing to listen to before
you're going to go get in a fistfight.
Yeah.
It's a fucking good song,
man.
You can't not have that good song anymore.
It's not responsible for the hurricane.
Okay.
Now if he played like walking on sunshine
by Katrina and the waves that then
that would be like,
wait,
why is he fucking playing this?
This doesn't go along with this sport.
I wonder if you'd be allowed to do that.
And one of Dana [inaudible]
cause he approves every song
he approved smacked.
By the way,
smacking my bitch.
I was one like all these awards,
it's like,
you know it's in Charlie's angels smack
my bishop was in Charlie's angels.
How does that go?
It's like,
like complaining,
smacked up big bit.
It's like this crazy like techno.
It's a really famous song.
He never heard it before.
I probably have the names
just not ringing a bell.
Is it like it is the chemical
brothers and I am familiar with it.
I have like all their stuff.
I guess just hilarious though that
someone would complain about that.
Like that seems like kind of silly,
you know?
Of course.
What is it?
Anything about anything silly.
We nerfing the fucking world.
What is going on Brendan Walsh.
Now,
I asked you this because you're a
a comic and you're also a fucking,
you know,
you,
you go deep,
you push buttons,
you know,
you're uh,
you talk about crazy shit on stage.
It's fun.
It's my kind of comedy good.
You know,
when,
when I saw you the other
night at the ice house,
I was like,
thank God there's still
guys tilling that laddering,
man.
It's true.
You,
you been really dirty.
The new stuff's kind of
go deeper.
I was there.
Why?
I mean,
I look,
I,
I'm a huge fan of standup comedy.
He's still,
but it's not enough.
People are doing crazy shit.
I not enough.
Not Enough people are going
to the deep end of the pool,
you know,
there's not enough people are just
making fucked up things really funny.
You know?
And there's a few,
there's a few,
but you,
you were nailing a bunch of,
I don't want to do any of your material,
but you were nailing a
bunch of left and right.
I was like,
this is really funny stuff and I enjoyed
it that Taso does comedy supposed to be
kind of fucked up man?
The best stuff when you've
got a couple of drinks in you.
The best stuff like you know like Nick
Dipaolo is one of my all time favorite
guys to watch.
When I got a little buzz
on cause he would have
fake mean shit.
I mean it was me and it was a but B.
He's not a mean guy.
He's a nice guy.
He's a great guy.
He's just fucking,
that's the style of comedy and
he's going after it and it's,
and it's especially when
you've got a buzz on,
it's a fucking great art form and by
people complaining about a dude coming out
to rock you like a hurricane and by people
trying to take some of the flavor out
of,
out of,
out of the world tone things down there,
they're ruining everything
that's cool about life.
Yeah.
There's this subtlety.
Knowing what's right and
what's wrong and knowing when,
when to let things go and when to do this.
This is a big fucking,
it shows a big,
it's like prioritization.
Yeah.
If you're going to sit
down and fucking like,
you know,
police Wikipedia on your fucking own time.
Just because somebody adds,
Jerry Seinfeld's started directing
adult films after whatever,
you know,
like there's somebody who's,
policing Craig's list for like people
trying to be funny or gross on it.
Like fuck's wrong with you man.
I like the prior like there's a million
other things you could be doing right
now.
Yeah.
And that needs to be illuminated,
right?
It needs to be pointed at it.
Like why are you doing this?
Well,
because like usually what they're doing,
I mean I'm just speaking from experience
of like I had a fake Yelp account where
I would just complain about businesses.
Like I took businesses that had like,
there was a car wash called the
handy j and I wrote the review.
Like I was expecting a hand job at the
end of the car wash and it was blatant
false advertising.
And there's a restaurant called
the happy ending on sunset.
So either way I was just all written
by this naive guy who was in a shitty
marriage and he was just
looking for a hand job.
And none of these places hand jobs
and his pink Taco place in Arizona.
Like some guy beats the shit out of him
cause he tries to get his daughter to
fuck.
I mean it was just a
silly thing I was doing,
but he got taken down because
I guess somebody you know,
complained or was monitoring
Yelp and I lost all my fucking,
uh,
he didn't write hand John Anywhere again.
No,
I was like,
I,
that's before I even knew that
you could do a screen grab.
Like I just,
I think I,
well wasn't there a thing that
you could do on the Internet,
Brian,
where you could go back in time?
I go,
yeah.
Not just that.
Oh,
you could go and,
yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
but that,
that,
that probably is not on there.
I don't know.
It was a couple of years ago.
And how does that work?
What it does is it's,
it's just a program,
you know,
like a spider or a Bot that takes
screenshots and kind of saves websites,
kind of archives of websites
called the Internet archive.
And it works all stored at uh,
I dunno,
I think it's connected with some museum
or something like that or some kind of
weird thing.
I'm like,
hmm,
need a base.
But it,
it,
it does,
it works like 70% of the time.
Like you can go to your
old website from like 91,
you know.
Well website 91 or 92 or whatever,
98 and uh,
you
could see it and some things will work.
Some photos we'll work some things.
Wow.
You know,
that's,
that's wild.
Yeah,
it is weird.
I Pepsi Spice Projects on there somewhere.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Brian did a thing where he pretended that
he was eat nothing but Pepsi spice for
like months and he got Pepsis vice.com
it was a titan new type of Pepsi did they
had Pepsi spice.com he registered it
because they were fucking slow on the take
and they didn't realize
the power of the Internet.
It's the only writes his blog detailing
these horrific fucking physical ailments
that are occurring to shedding.
So just eating nothing but Pepsi place.
What was it?
Spicy Pepsi.
Ginger.
Remember that shit at all.
It was horrible.
Awful was like thanksgiving.
Do you remember new coke?
They tried to farm member.
New coach.
Yeah.
It was classic.
It was like,
what are you doing?
And then they don't do that anymore.
Right now they got rid of Newco.
Yeah,
a new coach.
This was w it was a slow introduction,
you know,
was like,
it was like the metric system.
They tried to shove it up and
then they pulled it back there.
All right.
We give up,
give up.
We go up.
New Coke just tasted like Pepsi.
Do you think there's a different type
of person that drinks coke rather than
Pepsi?
Fuck yeah man.
I Hate Pepsi.
Like drinking Pepsi is kind of the same.
Diet Pepsi better than Diet Coke.
Zero rows do dumber people
like Pepsi or Smarter,
Dumber Drinking Soda on a regular basis.
I bet they are smart people.
I probably smoked cigarettes.
We,
this guy is Daniel Pinchbeck.
This brilliant author told me
just quit smoking cigarettes.
I was like,
what the fuck you want,
but you just quit to write tough man.
When did you quit?
I'm flake.
On my third day.
So that's it.
Not even,
I quit for a year a couple of years ago
and I smoked a joint with my friend,
rolled a joint with tobacco
in it and it fucking,
it's crazy once you have that
little taste that was like,
hey,
wrote me a cigarette.
Like a couple of days later I was staying
with them in upstate New York after
Montreal and so it was kind of on vacation
and that vacation mode and was like,
oh,
I have a couple of smokes
until when I get back to La,
I'll stop and went down to the city for
a week and bombed a couple cigarettes.
But cigarettes are like
15 bucks a pack there.
So I was like,
I'm just going to buy a pack and you know,
give them the people and
I'll smile either way.
It just snowballed into,
is that the only physical
addiction you've ever had?
Um,
Cock Brian.
Yeah man,
that's rude.
That's rude behavior that you're
fucking going out on the Internet.
Other people are going to hear this,
that to slander or liable and
whatever it is in your mouth and cry.
Okay.
Listen,
you took it too far back?
No,
I've never had any real like,
you know,
I like to drink and stuff,
but you've never had like a,
a physical craving like that
before we got attached to it.
Cigarettes or alcohol or cigarettes
is the only one like that.
I mean how bad is alcohol?
Have you ever gotten to a I
need a drink every day stage?
No,
no,
no.
It's cigarettes.
My put,
what I was trying to get
at was like cigarettes are,
they're torn and really tough and,
and,
and much stronger.
They have a much stronger pull than a
lot of the other things to get people.
Well because you don't get anything
out of cigarettes to like cigarettes.
If they got you high or drunk wake
your poison,
like do you get pissed off with those
people that fucking telling you they can
smoke and they don't ever get hooked
because there's a lot of people that do
though whenever I want.
I think there are different kinds of,
like I do lean more towards like an
addictive like you know like if there's
something that's kind of fun I'll like,
my impulse is to overdo it.
I mean I have self
control and other things.
That's why you're funny.
Almost all comics have that.
Every conflict of interest.
It's really funny cause impulsive
Kreischer he's really impulsive.
Brian Keaulana really impulsive.
Joey's impulses.
Fuck.
You know,
I'm glad that they're still improving
the technology of a cigarette though.
They have camel crushes now,
which are so awesome.
Like you're smoking a
cigarette and you're like,
you know what,
I'm bored with this cigarette.
Then you just crushed a filter and we
releases more chemicals under the filter.
Then it tastes like mint.
So now I'm in Boston but
it's a little chemical.
Bollier
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
So you can change your experience.
You go from a regular or
at any time back and forth?
No,
no.
Just one menthol you or
has this available to it?
The whole pack.
Yeah.
They have little spearmint balls and I've
got to find out that
that gives cancer cancer.
Yeah,
definitely give your cancer
Batman,
but once you get out of the woods,
when I quit a couple of years ago,
I mean I went like a year and it's been
a year now that I spend smoking again.
Uh,
once you get out,
or at least once I got out of the woods,
like after a couple of weeks I was like,
okay,
fine.
I don't need this.
But then really?
Yeah,
I really didn't.
I was pretty cocky about it.
I was like,
I'm never going to stick another one
of those things in my mouth and I could
have,
I would hang out at bars.
I'd go out with my friends
when they went to smoke,
I was like,
I'm done.
I don't smoke.
I read this book that helped a lot.
I mean,
granted I'm smoking again,
but because,
well,
but I mean,
under my circumstances though,
I kind of didn't really do it by choice.
Like I smoked this joint that had tobacco
and I knew I tasted it right away,
but I was like,
ah,
I could fuck it.
I'm going to say this is like,
it's been 11 months
since I had a cigarette.
I can have a pop tobacco demon
talking to you fucked up.
So it is the nicotine demon.
Well that's the way the guy see that's
the way he describes it in the book is
like you're just feeding this little
monster that needs to be fed over.
Like it's a very short,
I even heard that like after CCI or
whatever you get to like it starts burning
fat that has nicotine still in it and so
you start getting cravings again after
like a certain period.
Love
is bullshit.
Someone said that too and I
thought that sounded silly.
It seems kind of silly.
It might be though.
I mean I know marijuana
stays in your system.
I think if you're like really
fat and he gets super high,
we can stay in your system for weeks.
Yeah.
It stays in your fat styles,
right?
Yeah.
So if that,
I mean,
if it's there,
maybe,
I mean it's obviously the grip of
that stuff is way stronger than,
I mean there's people that say
they get addicted to marijuana,
but there's nothing like the feeling
that I don't think that they get with
cigarettes.
They don't need to smoke it all day low.
It's more of a habitual,
I think,
marijuana to you get,
you get hooked on the ritual of it.
I also have this shit.
Yeah,
I'm willing to,
I'm willing to believe that everybody
has a different biochemistry and some
people can get physically addicted to
almost anything because I think people
gets physically addicted to sugar.
You know,
some people that like have crazy sugar
fixations where it's an addiction,
you know,
so they could get addicted to marijuana,
but nothing like the
addiction to cigarettes.
That is one of the weirdest ones,
man.
It's like when you see people,
like when Brian,
when Brian started
smoking cigarettes again,
it's almost like I have to accept
that he got bit by a vampire,
you got
cigarettes,
makes me want to have a cigarette.
Oh Dude.
Are you ever going to quit or you just,
yeah.
Oh really?
You're ready to given
today's been rough plaza,
but no,
I should,
I've just been,
you know,
I keep fucking want in line,
but it's like,
yeah,
it's that,
what is it?
Tell,
explain it to me.
What is it?
What does the,
what's the pull as a person who's never,
it's a,
I've had a cigarette or two in the day,
but I've never got it.
Yeah,
it's just,
it seems,
it's sounds like a really good idea.
Like I just want to kind of fucking smoke
a cigarette and there is a little bit
of a,
yeah,
a little lake.
You know what it's like when you go and
you're hungry is fuck and you like the
movie theater and he smelled
that popcorn and you're like,
fuck,
I need that popcorn.
No,
there can be,
it's gotta be way crazier than that.
Cause I can pass it down.
No,
because you can sit there
and not get popcorn.
But if you sit there and keep on
smelling it over and over again,
I mean he'll drive me crazy.
Don't you still think
of popcorn specifically?
Think of like you're really hungry
and you smell like fucking hell.
Fogo de Chao and the guy keeps coming
back with the meat and I have my thing
flipped over to read.
Is it that good?
It's,
yeah,
it's,
it's more than that.
It just like,
we smell like,
like somebody cooking cookies or
brownies in your house and you're like,
oh,
I need that fucking cookie now.
It's like that.
That's what the yearnings kind of like,
like it's something where it's like,
oh,
when you get it,
when you finally give into the beast and
you're a bitch up and you suck it in,
what does that like?
That completely goes away.
That stress.
It goes away and then,
but then I guess
no,
mine's immediately going
to be followed by guilt.
Yeah,
but you don't do,
you don't think,
okay,
here I am.
I'm poisoning
dude.
Oh God,
the thoughts I fucking go through my head.
That's so dumb.
I think about it like I don't
think about when I'm doing it.
Like I think about it
the next morning went on,
did
you start smoking a pipe?
Yeah.
Smells better.
Tobacco,
maybe you could smoke a pipe and be okay.
Just,
you just got to stop doing it
because they're both junkies.
You
guys can't help it,
man.
But you know,
this is like,
you know,
yeah,
it's my third day.
So it's pretty,
it's awesome.
No,
you see that's,
I'm not a big daytime smoker.
Like I don't,
I use it for a lot of
smoke during the day.
If I'm with lunch.
So you don't eat,
like,
if I'm really hungry,
I'm just too busy.
I'll smoke a cigarette and that
kills it for another 30 minutes.
Oh my God.
That's so gross.
Yeah.
That's gotta be terrible for you.
But I do,
if I'm around people,
like I was staying with a buddy of mine
in Austin and he wakes up in the morning
and has a cup of coffee and a
cigarette and I would do that.
Oh,
well it's just,
it's more like,
oh,
again,
like when in Rome,
like,
okay,
but I wouldn't do that on like give
you a crazy head rush was I do for you?
You know,
I'm not crazy about that.
Uh,
that Combo first thing in the morning?
No,
it makes my stomach whereby shitty.
I know,
but even before they have food.
Yeah.
No,
I think,
I think a lot of people are really,
what's the big deal?
I don't know.
It just goes together.
Perfect.
It's the taste of the coffee and the
tasty over figure shit out from that
combination.
Is that a combination where you start
your day out with a new perspective?
You get a little boost from the cigarette.
Little boost from the
coffee at the same time.
It's kind of like a kickstart.
Amazing,
amazing shit.
Nobody ever talks about
getting rid of cigarettes.
They're like little,
little evil demons to the,
they should be fuck elected themselves.
Illegal.
It's amazing.
It's amazing when you think about
all the shit that is illegal.
You think of the actual
numbers that they're doing.
We were talking,
I was talking to Henry Phillips about the,
I don't know if you guys know Henry,
but a guy who played guitar on Stan hopes
and we were just like,
you know,
Kinda drunk talking on the phone one
night and we were both talking about how
like,
God,
what are we still smoking?
You know,
cause he smoked cigarettes too.
And uh,
he was saying like,
yeah,
if like an alien life form was like
looking down on us and they'd be like,
wait,
so this fucking thing kills you know,
like a million people a
year and it's not illegal.
Like why don't they just make it illegal?
And it's like,
well cause these five guys are
getting really rich off of it.
And he's like,
when the aliens would be like,
well why not just kill those five guys
and save like the millions and just make
it like,
it seems like a no brainer,
but it's like,
yeah,
that's just the way
everything's fucked up.
It's like,
yeah,
why not just kill the five guys who
are fucking everything up for everyone?
Well there's two arguments.
Is one the freedom of x or you know,
the freedom argument where you're,
you're free to do whatever you want to do,
even if it's heroin if you want to,
but why can't you?
Because it's illegal.
But should we allow
more things to be legal?
That's the other question.
It's like we have enough.
No,
I'm saying make cigarettes.
It would be hard because a lot of people
say they want to be able to have a
fucking cigarette.
I know,
but I think a lot of people
want to fuck 10 year olds,
two
cigarettes.
They legalized fucking 10 year olds.
That might be way more
addictive than cigarettes.
I've never done it.
The is
connecting to you.
You fucking 10 year olds is you
interfering with other people's lives.
You're making your own.
You have your own personal freedom
to go and to this obviously being,
I know of course,
but it's a weird thing that you want to
say that it is illegal because I think
you should be able to do whatever the
fuck you want and then if you want to
smoke cigarettes and they,
you know,
they're addicted.
I think we should look down horribly
on the people who sell them.
You know,
just like any person selling
any fucking deadly drug.
I mean especially things that just,
what are those 599 fucking ingredients
that they've added to cigarettes to make
them more addictive?
Like what a crazy combo
they've put together.
Smoke those American spirits almost
my whole career they have the,
their whole thing is,
it's 100% additive free tobacco,
like whole foods,
cigarettes.
Is it less addictive?
Nicotine's pretty addicted to nicotine.
Nine itself is addictive enough
and all the $500 shit is like
to make it,
it's like,
like what they do to food at Mcdonald's.
Like it's designed to have to burn a
certain way for the ash to be shaped
this certain way.
Do you,
um,
do you notice the difference between the,
the cigarette experience from Lego,
the natural ones and the
ones like the cool lights or,
yeah,
as well as the different,
what do you,
you spoke about camel camel lights,
but when I decided a
really strong one isn't it?
Campbell's really strong American spirits
actually to me feel like they do more
damage just because it's a thicker,
they last longer,
they last long.
Like I'll smoke like,
you know,
American spirits the next day
I'm coughing up black shit.
Like I feel like focus many of them.
I mean that's,
you can't smoke as many
or like I always find so
when z it's so ridiculous.
Like how do you take your poison,
uh,
you know,
you gotta be careful
with the natural poison.
Natural poisons.
Hard to swallow.
Well I think it's just,
it's a no,
you see,
I don't think it's hard to swell.
I just don't think you
want it as frequently.
Like the other ones burn faster
and like diet pop you can,
you can just keep getting knocked down
to camels for like one of camels used to
have no filter.
They are filled.
They still have,
they all,
all cigarettes have like no filter
and filter like lucky strikes,
you know,
come wherever it doesn't matter.
Well they have some morrow.
Yeah,
they have non unfiltered Marlboros too.
I don't know if they stole mine.
I don't know if the camel,
no filters.
Awesome.
No,
I know that.
Yeah.
What is,
what is that all about?
What's the non,
yeah,
that's like some dude who's
a fucking rockabilly shit.
He going to the nth degree
to fucking maintain.
Why else are you smoking lucky
strikes except for the package.
It looks cool and goes good with your
fucking bowling shirt with flags on it.
Like a grease back hair.
You're fucking tattoo of
a howling cartoon dog.
I don't want to give any more
descriptions cause has got,
I don't get punched in the
face of one of those guys.
Know what?
I'm an author and there's those girls
that have that very specific to those
files,
but bro ask or you were
talking about that?
That's crazy.
In Austin like yeah.
Yeah.
They all dress like or some shit.
Yeah,
they seem is roller derby girls.
They're all cut from the same cloth.
He went,
the fuck is this longing for the
style path that everybody has?
I don't know.
I have a joke about it where
I say I love Roller Derby.
I've never seen it,
but I liked that exist because it cuts
down on all the crappy girl bands.
It would be around otherwise
some attention.
It's like,
yeah,
don't start a band dude.
Yeah,
dude,
that fucking do bro.
Lasker,
uh Oh,
that's fun.
Or Roller Derby.
Have a friend from the message board
that's in a roller derby thing.
Vicky,
from the message board.
Well it's,
it's just a joke,
but she's her.
She's a nice girl,
but she gave me a roller derby
girl tee shirt or wear it.
Oh yeah,
no,
it's a cool thing.
Like Roller Derby girl tee shirt.
Yeah,
it was fucking podcast is over.
It's things gone forever,
man.
And was leaving.
I rambled.
We rambled through a good part of it
where I didn't know what the fuck we were
talking about getting part.
I was not awake.
We too tired.
You know.
That's the problem with
doing a late night one.
I work all day doing fear factor.
I'm out in the fucking hot sun all day.
That shit cooks your brain.
You can drink a lot of
water and rehydrating helps,
but it makes you really stupid.
At the end of the day.
Just curly.
Tarred.
How many,
can you see how many people
started listening and stop
just to 1,276 not bad for
the end.
I've been on forever.
Two one half hours,
right?
It's 11:00 PM on the east coast.
Ah,
fuck,
fuck.
Or on the west coast,
whether it's 11:00 PM.
All right.
Um,
thank you Brendon for coming.
Bye.
That was all asking me.
Please follow him on Twitter.
It's B r e n.
D can put a date.
Walsh.
Hell yes on B R.
Walsh.
Yeah.
I tweet on Twitter and I'll be in uh,
Bloomington,
Indiana at the comedy attic.
September 29th refers.
Tweet that and I'll retweet it.
And if you've never seen him
go fucking see it will be fun.
That's hilarious.
You're one of those guys that right now
in my book of like funny guys to watch.
You're one of those that hasn't
been nationally recognized yet,
but it's going to happen quick.
Cool,
man.
I really believe that.
You're a fucking hilarious dude.
The other night at the,
at the Ice House.
You had a shows were fun.
Really Fun.
Yeah,
they're great.
we're really lucky and most of it is
these fucking freaks and they're listening
right now.
And we'll be in Houston.
You dirty freaks.
Yeah,
we're going to be in Houston together.
We're going to be there with
the Great Joey Coco Diaz.
It's a bonafide experience,
ladies and gentlemen.
And what does that like?
October 7th,
October 7th and that said
the Verizon wireless theater.
And uh,
this weekend,
September 23rd?
Yeah.
September 23rd I'm with,
um,
Joey and Ari and we're
going to be in Denver,
Colorado and we're at the paramount
theater and it's almost sold out.
Um,
such,
it's going to be a lot of fucking,
I haven't been back to
Denver in a long time,
so I'm looking forward to that.
So that should be the shirt.
And then the weekend after that,
uh,
October,
the first week in October.
Oh No,
the 30th,
the 30th of September.
I'm in Washington DC and
that's at the Warner theater.
And that's what Ari should fear.
Alright,
you dirty pictures.
Yeah.
You guys are awesome.
Thanks for tuning in.
Thanks for lasting all
you use stream freaks.
You hung in there and all your people,
yet they listening to
this at the gym and go,
this is a very disjointed
fucking Weirdo podcast.
Yes and no.
Surely we could edit this and get the
good parts and it would be an hour and 45
minutes of absolute deliciousness.
This would be really good at one 41
45 this podcast would be the shit,
but I'm sorry we don't
have that for you today.
We have two hours and 20 minutes
of disjointed conversations.
Some of it's entertaining,
thousands of pieces on you.
Some of it is just plain
[inaudible] so thanks.
Thanks for tuning in to the podcast and
thanks for everything and thanks to the
flashlight for sponsoring the podcast.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight
and enter in the code name Rogan.
You will get 15% off the top
one sex door from oh shit.
Brandon wants to going to
take one home with them.
I don't shoot mad loads and that shit.
Son.
I don't know if I can trust myself.
Well,
yeah,
maybe I will.
You're going to do it.
I'm going to be back on Sunday this Sunday
evening with Graham Hancock and that
is going to be fucking awesome.
My one of my favorite authors of all time,
if you've never heard of him,
go look them up online and watch
some of his videos on youtube.
Google on by his books,
fingerprints of the Gods changed
the way I looked at the world.
And uh,
he's going to be here this Sunday,
so,
well,
that's it.
I'll see you guys soon.
Thanks for everything.
Bye.
Yeah.